[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou ludiques dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 20 octobre le
parc france miniature se pare de ses
plus belles couleurs ambiance automnale
est monstrueux zde ce dimanche 22
octobre pour halloween des animations
sont proposées le directeur du parc nous
présentera ses nouveaux résidents des
personnages hauts en couleur et on
restera sur cette thématique pour notre
rendez-vous junior la maison elsa
triolet aragon propose de créer votre
propre petit monstre et de participer
non plus aidé aux géantes
enfin ce week end débute le 16e tournoi
d'automne du club d'échecs de la dame
noire ce club de montigny le bretonneux
fête bientôt ses 30 ans et les
inscriptions sont ouvertes pour le
rejoindre
tout d'abord un clin d'oeil à l'acteur
yves binois omar sy knock son dernier
film est sorti mercredi dernier en salle
l'occasion de le découvrir dans le rôle
d'un médecin un peu voyou qui tente de
convaincre les villageois qui sont tous
malades
nous l'avions rencontrée lors de l'avant
première à l'ugc skywest écoutez le dans
ce film il ya on parle aussi de la
rédemption la deuxième chance des choses
qui peuvent se modifier dans le bon sens
et donc des valeurs intéressantes cdd
notion intéressante et j'aime bien
défini qui parle de ça donc je suis
content d'y participer
l'intégralité de cet entretien est donc
à retrouver sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme et on ouvre maintenant
une thématique halloween avec notre
invité
[Musique]
halloween c'est bien l'événement attendu
pendant les vacances de la toussaint qui
débutent ce 20 octobre avec new fabris
la loure directeur aveu directeur du
parc france miniature pour nous parler
des animations proposées jusqu'au 31
octobre jour de la fête d'halloween
bonjour moi je commis est avec nous
également sur notre plateau mélanie
poquet pour notre rendez-vous junior
alors qu'on vous prend un peu plus tard
avec vous d'autres activités monstrueuse
bonjour on verra on n'aura peur on aura
fort bond va j'espère bien en tout cas
donc avant toute chose à fabrice la
loure j'aimerais qu'on parle de vos
nouveaux résidents or depuis quelques
jours des créatures étranges et élu
domicile dans votre parc
ça y est le parc à fleury et s'est ornée
de citrouilles en toujours sur le
parquet une nouvelle créature vont
arriver dès ce week-end en effet dès ce
dimanche 22 octobre pour faire doucement
peur à nos visiteurs alors qu'ils sont
ils là est ce que vous nommez présenter
la troupe focus avec qui on avait
travaillé depuis quelques années
notamment pour la toussaint d'année
dernière reprend vie sur le parquet va
nous racontait des tas de contes et des
légendes qui sont rattachés au monument
du parc évidemment sur une thématique un
peu effrayante donc ils ont proposé un
petit peu l'histoire de chaque monument
pour trouver des petites scènes un peu
inquiétante alors comment ça se passe
très concrètement les visiteurs viennent
ils sont pris en charge des visites la
journée commença alors la visite reste
libre sur le parc l'éditeur sont libres
ou non de participer à ces événements
mais c'est plutôt amusant de pouvoir
suivre la troupe en effet et c'est
l'occasion de faire une dit un petit peu
différente parce qu'ils vont ils vont
parcourir le parc et avoir un autre oeil
sur les monuments et sera l'histoire des
ces monuments donc à des horaires précis
il ya des horaires enfin c'est tout là
c'est toute la journée on aura la troupe
qui sera présente sur le site mais il y
aura des sera rythmée dans l'est dans la
dans la journée et on précisera ses
horaires à nos visiteurs en matinée
maintenant quand il arrive sur le dans
le parc est ce que vous nous présentez
du coup la compagnie focus ça fait
longtemps vous travaillez avec cette
compagnie on avait eu l'occasion de
travailler avec eux sur d'autres
évènements par le passé il se trouve que
les dernières sur la thématique
halloween il était présent et on avait
bien aimé leur approche il avait su
répondre vraiment à nos attentes
là encore de trouver des désaxés des
orientations un petit peu différente et
puissant tout collé aussi à l'histoire
de ces monuments voulais vraiment que ça
soit rattachée à l'histoire de france
miniature également et vous
juste avant l'entretien que l'idée n'est
pas de faire peur on ne pas effrayer non
plus les jeunes visiteurs sociale et pts
et aux plus petits c'est ça on a
beaucoup de familles avec enfants donc
on se fait doucement peur sur le parc
donc les personnages qui nous
accompagnent dans le cadre de la troupe
focus savent être il ya des gargouilles
un peu étranger à des échassiers mais
c'est tout un mélange de magie de
jonglerie d'acrobatie et et on se fait
douce menteur alors un mot sur les
modalités cette animation est comprise
dans le prix des visites et un prix des
billets c'est ça c'est un complément à
la visite c'est un plus à la visite n'y
a pas de surcoût à 7
cette prestation et les des 21 euros
pour les adultes 15 euros pour les
enfants puisque sont aux tarifs ils ont
accès également à ces animations et à
l'ensemble aussi du parquet donc on va
le rappeler donc ça commence ses
animations spéciales halloween commence
dimanche 22 octobre se poursuivre
jusqu'au mardi 31 octobre et j'aimerais
qu'on évoque un peu plus largement le
parc pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore eu
l'occasion de découvrir plusieurs
nouveautés ont été mises en place dès le
mois d'avril
et je pense notamment à la nouvelle
animation fort boyard qui a eu beaucoup
de succès a priori cet été le parc
s'enrichit chaque année soit d'animation
soit de nouveau monument soit depuis
quelques années on a cherché une
nouvelle orientation c'était celle de
d'attraction et les cette année en tout
début
2le d'avril 2010 est on a fait rentrer
fort boyard sur le parquet ont proposé à
nos visiteurs une immersion dans le jeu
télévisé et de se confronter aux maîtres
du fort et au père fouras et et nîmes
alors qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait retrouver
notamment qu'est ce qu'on peut retrouver
comme
comme communiquent mais comme je à faire
alors on va retrouver donc le grand
classique de la salle du conseil de fort
boyard
on va là encore essayé de jouer à
l'awalé à des jeux de de mémoire
visuelle on va essayer de répondre à des
questions qui sont posées par le père
fouras depuis des écrans et puis on va
pouvoir aussi joué là c'est un petit peu
plus physique il faut se défier avec des
cotons tiges géants et se faire tomber
de qu'une poutre
donc voilà il ya la fois à des petites
questions intellectuelle et puis dépit
du sport et physiques pour les familles
et des défis bien connu des
téléspectateurs ça s'adresse justement
en ce qu'ils ont mission cammas est
emblématique donc aux petits comme aux
grands là pour le coup même les parents
peuvent y trouver un peu leur pense
c'est très familial
et ça ça compte entre tout le monde est
ce qui explique aussi le succès qu'on a
rencontrées cette année puisque chaque
année on accueille un peu plus de
visiteurs et cette année on a accueilli
près de 195 milles visiteurs sur la
période d'ouverture donc une belle une
belle année en pourront du coup une très
belle année 2010 est en effet un avis
aux retardataires parce que la fermeture
arrive bientôt la fermeture hivernale du
parc c'est le 5 novembre vous allez nous
prévoir quelques nouveautés du coup pour
2018 alors des nouveautés pour la saison
prochaine llodra dans le cadre
d'animations
on essaiera d'apporter chaque mois des
nouveautés pour nos visiteurs des
l'occasion de rencontrer des abeilles
avoir des ateliers sur les abeilles et
découvrir des jours des tous les mois de
mai sur on aura l'occasion d'animations
médiévales également des chasses aux
brouillards et trésor dans des ateliers
des chantiers de fouille pour les
enfants qui pourront jouer aux
archéologues enfin bas ponctué toute la
saison 2010 8 d'animation tant qu'à
suivre de très près en tout cas merci
beaucoup fabrice louvre pour tous et
pour tous de ces informations concernant
halloween à france miniature et france
miniature de manière plus générale on le
rappelle la compagnie focus vous emmène
dans leurs comptes jusqu'au 31 octobre
et pensez à vous rendre sur le site
internet pour avoir plus d'information
merci beaucoup fabrice la logique et on
reste dans cette thématique d'halloween
avec mélanie poquet et notre rendez-vous
junior
[Musique]
alors mélanie cette semaine vous en vous
emmener à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
savas qui sonnait savent après sonné à
la maison triolet aragon parce qu'elle
passe en mode halloween et les vacances
aussi faut pas l'oublier alors la fête
halloween cela fait d'aussi on s'amuse à
se faire pas on s'amuse
c'est vraiment important ces deux mots
alors deux activités sur deux journées
sont prévues les 25 et 26 octobre
prochain alors la première c'est pour
les 8 12 ans avec un cluedo
un meurtre a été commis à la maison
triolet aragon et les enfants vont
devoir enquêter
ok les énigmes à résoudre dans les
différentes pièces de la maison
avec à chaque fois des cartes à
retrouver donc innocente tel ou tel
personnage qui font en sorte que je sais
que telle ou telle pièce est une telle
ou telle arme est exclu une fois
l'énigme résolue un goûter attendra les
enfants le créneau du 26 octobre est
victime de son succès il est déjà
complet mais la maison triolet aragon a
sans doute proposer un autre atelier le
27 octobre le clodo c'est donc pour les
plus grands alors pour les moins de 8
ans alors pour les moins de 8 ans et l'a
cette fois ci les 4 7 ans et eux ils
créeront une marionnette monstrueuse une
marionnette chaussettes alors je pense
que ça va vous intrigue à mieux écouter
on va avoir bien sûr du coloriage du
découpage donc c'est aussi un
apprentissage qu'on fait tout au long de
notre vie mais 5 le découpage est
ensuite coller tous les éléments sur les
chaussettes pour en faire un vrai
monstre ou à partir et bien d'une simple
chaussettes et ensuite on va en faire un
vrai monstre on va y ajouter des dents
des yeux des cheveux un peu dans tous
les sens et ça à faire donc les
personnages de notre compte final alors
je vous rassure camille pas besoin de
venir avec sa propre chaussette les
animateurs les ont déjà derrière il
faudra réfléchir aux personnages de sa
marionnette
amandine que vous avez entendu proposera
un début d'histoire les enfants devront
créer la suite là aussi un goûter
terminera l'atelier pour les
informations pratiques les ateliers ont
lieu de 15 heures à 17 heures attention
les places sont limitées et les
inscriptions obligatoires toutes les
informations s'affichent en bas de
l'écran
merci beaucoup mélanie poquet pour ses
différentes aussi
et on referme maintenant notre
thématique halloween mais on reste à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines une poésie de
la nature c'est en ces termes que la
maison elsa triolet aragon présente sa
nouvelle exposition à découvrir jusqu'à
fin novembre
les oeuvres de nils oudot plonge le
visiteur dans un monde végétal de
l'infiniment petit aux paysages
grandioses l'exposition se divise en
deux salles l'une consacrée aux
peintures de l'artiste l'autre à ses
photographies pionnier du land art
il s'est entouré d'autres artistes pour
réaliser ces installations pierre colas
de la maison triolet aragon nous
explique le principe ces installations
qui sont mises en place par des artistes
dans relations même dans des déserts ou
dans des forêts avec les matériaux trinh
duc sur place on y voit dans
l'exposition quelques quelques fleurs de
campanules qui sont sur une feuille de
châtaigniers et on a l'impression d'une
barque à la dérive il a réalisé des
peintures dans lequel il exprime aussi
toute une botanique intime personnel
on a l'impression dans l'exposition de
peinture de ventre et comme tout en vain
dans une forêt dense et à travers les
sous bois au bois de petit à petit notre
regard s'accoutumer et là on distingue
quelques formes des troncs transparent
des des lumières qui miroite et le bleu
des eaux
avis aux passionnés ce week-end débute
le 16e tournoi d'automne d'automne du
club d'échecs de la dame noire de
montigny le bretonneux
un événement qui rassemble chaque année
petits et grands les plus motivés sont
invités à participer pour les curieux il
est possible de venir assister à
quelques parties petite présentation de
ce club qui fêtera ses 30 ans l'an
prochain des coupes des prix une
quarantaine de récompenses gagnées au
fil des années par le club d'échecs de
la dame noire depuis 1988 il s'est
imposé comme un incontournable à
montigny le bretonneux
au départ il n'y avait pas de club à
montigny et puis donc c'est des gens qui
étaient au club du chenet qui ont ont
décidé de créer un nouveau club à
montigny c'est un club à ces actifs ont
fait différents tournois et on joue tous
les tous les vendredis soir et on donne
des cours
le fan des premiers parmi les tournois
celui d'automne pendant les vacances de
la toussaint un tournoi de neuf rondes
avec une partie par jour un rythme
soutenu qui s'adresse avant tout à des
initiés c'est un jeu qui est très
exigeant donc il faut je pense d'abord
se préparer un peu physiquement c'est à
dire par une vis relativement saine pour
pouvoir aborder dans de bonnes
conditions les partis qui sont quand
même assez long commence à 14h elle
termine en tourne à 19 heures il faut du
sérieux faut arriver à être un peu
solide c'est-à-dire à maîtriser quelque
part c'est émotion par toute l'année à
faire jouer un coup qu'on n'avait pas
prévu aujourd'hui le club compte une
soixantaine d'adhérents de 6 à 80 ans il
recherche toujours des candidats pour
transmettre sa passion des échecs
la 16e édition de ce tournoi d'automne
se déroulera du 21 au 29 octobre et on
passe à notre agenda avec deux derniers
rendez vous à noter le domaine de
rambouillet participent à l'événement
national monument jeu d'enfant qui se
déroule tout le week-end la thématique
prince hans elle fit un atelier proposé
autour de l'exposition sur les princes
de rambouillet le matin et l'après midi
réservation obligatoire le jeune indien
yakari et son cheval petit tonnerre
prennent leurs quartiers à versailles
pour une exposition leur papa des rip
sera également présent ce week end
l'auteur rencontrera son public et
dédicacera ses albums dès 14 heures
samedi et dimanche de 7 8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis j'espère que vous avez fait le
plein d'idées sorties pour le week end
et pour la semaine à venir n'oubliez pas
de retrouver votre mission sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme je vous
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
où
m